hey what's happening thanks for tuning
in to another episode of what to be
talked today different style of episode
Spicer's down at the e3 video game
convention playing [ __ ] games a grown
man EP you & could make it taste I said
I don't care I'm going down there all
things comedy maybe take some calls but
what I plan to do is I'm going to drop a
bonus episode on Thursday this will be
the front of it and then my guest is
Jennie Wade who is an incredible actress
and you can check her out on Twitter and
Instagram Ginny Jay Wade she's done so
much work man I mean it's it's crazy
when you meet people in this biz and
they just work non-stop like my boy Mike
beach you know people always get in
projects it's great she's uh she's a
guest you grew up in Oregon on a kind of
a cult e church kind of thing she talks
about so we get into a religious cults
she plays banjo banjo pretty [ __ ]
crazy and and she's good plays down at
Largo and she also is super cool so
that'll be after this little mini let
there be talk no Spicer episode I just
want to talk about what's going on here
today wait we got a call we'll grab that
and then we'll get into it hey what's
going on who's calling yeah hey yo man
who's that hard jetting out from clear
what's going on man hey man were you
laughing about I'm in New York's well oh
yeah coming out to New York County yeah
answer be there I'm up in Westchester
County I'm coming out to New York yeah I
wanted to ask you about that I'm going
away the 23rd of July yeah well I
that week oh that when you were coming
no why i'm in toronto on july 22 23 and
then doing the corner if you guys live
in toronto then I'm coming to New York
for like two weeks so I get there in the
26 and i'll be there till august eighth
and i'll call it there and that August
week that that would be great we're
going to be be doing shows and also
podcasting with a bunch of new york
guess awesome man great I got Don
Jameson's gonna do it try to get Artie
Lange and Jim Norton stuff like that and
maybe some new york musicians different
people from the east coast that I tell
mary much yep hey um I just wanted to
say also i'm listening right now to the
butch walker podcast oh yeah and it's
fresh it's fresh in my mind that you
opened up talking about the guy in
orlando killing everybody in the hate
and why people hate and all that oh yeah
that's is it horrible man just orlando
just hear the more it's crazy i feel
like i can't i can't turn on the
internet now every day it's just these
tragedies it's just horrible yeah
exactly and I was gonna say that that
guy Isis also don't forget that part of
it you know he's he's Isis yeah he
definitely they they have he was yelling
out that one of those praise Allah Akbar
[ __ ] you know something crazy like that
and now they're saying that he's
definitely uh definitely are pledging
allegiance to Isis yeah I don't know
about that I just I just wait on stuff
like that because they jumped on that
right away you know yeah but if you say
or something that doesn't mean you are
something yeah right i mean you know a
comic yeah yeah i mean you know it's
it's uh it doesn't matter what you are
if you're to me that was a hate crime if
you're if you're going and taking out a
certain community you know um and
you know I don't like to dwell on it
because it's just such a heavy heavy
topic for podcasting and it can go down
a rabbit hole of just hours and hours
and and it becomes it becomes hot
buttons of people talking about gun
control it becomes religion sexuality
anything becomes these things I I try to
stay away from because there's nothing
but people that sit home and and they're
angry and they just like to get on the
internet and fire stuff up so I like i
always say promote what's great not what
you hate you know exactly yeah here it's
crazy out there but you know ah it's yes
as there as the election gets closer and
anger happens and stuff it's it's crazy
out there man you know I saw I saw a
clip i sent it to a few friends on
Instagram it was on Instagram yesterday
and I wish I'll figure out how to repost
it and it was a clip of two people on
motorcycles and they I guess they were
riding and they flipped a guy off that
cut them off so when they get to a
stoplight they're sitting at the
stoplight the UH it's like a it's like a
blazer pulls up and the guys that gay
[ __ ] you and the guy on the bikes like
[ __ ] you man get out of the car and the
guy in the car just run some over what
runs him and his lady over full-on on
camera it's incredible he mows over them
like a like a like you ever see those
footage of like jeeps going over
boulders and stuff it's like that he's
just he's just mowing over this guy and
drives away and I'm thinking to myself
first of all they got you on camera
you're gonna go to prison for that for
you
one minute of rage you're going to
prison that's attempted murder you know
why would you know what I mean I just
don't you know like people they got
these short fuses and and they're not
thinking man that that is kidding you're
going to jail for that you're going to
prison it's just crazy whoo you know so
sick world is a sick world man it is
that's why you ought to just uh you know
I try to just enjoy the good stuff you
know Sunday but Walker and I went riding
and as I wrote down the PCH and looked
out at Malibu I was like hey man you
know I got to just take this in it's
almost like medication if you get your
face out of the phone and just start
kind of reliving I saw Tom Green today I
don't know if it was real because Tom
Green is uh is a funny wacky dude but he
had some kind of dumb little beginners
phone and he said today I would take for
a bit child's like five-year-olds or
something just buttons and a send and
end and he said today is my first day of
ending my addiction to smartphones and
he got rid of it and he's going to just
use this nothing to look at except the
world I think I think you become a
funnier person too if you put down the
phone I think you know cuz now you're
starting to see [ __ ] yeah ya hear you
man I mean the main thing I use the
phone floor yeah keep up with my bands
and looks alone my podcasts and unfollow
my my sports teams that's what yeah the
move sucks yeah the news is uh you know
they only they only give you bad news so
I never see any good news you know and
also i would say i was saying a couple
days to somebody you know you got to be
out there and live your life because you
know who knows what's going to happen
you know oh yeah thanks for calling in
dude Oh
forward to seeing you meet me out there
in New York okay Dean I love the podcast
man keep it going crazy man candles lit
buddy thank you it's crazy crazy stuff
out there I tell you what's really crazy
is today in LA it smells like somebody's
welding the entire city and i guess some
kind of plant blew up overnight there's
like a recycling plant your recycling
plant and it's just i get up this
morning to go running and I'm like whoa
what the [ __ ] is that it smells exactly
when you weld the entire city and alls
I'm thinking is like well that that's
that's shedding some years off our lives
yeah I mean there's no way that smell is
we're breathing it in there's no way
it's good for you no no it's it it
smells exact a welding and it like a
like a bird metal and it hasn't gone
away yet it's been burning for I guess
eight hours it's crazy man like just an
explosion at a recycling plant it's it's
[ __ ] the smell its way out to like
it's not close to eat Vernon or wherever
the hell that is I'll tell you what I
feel sorry for the people that it's
closed on because I'm I'm I'm huffing
this going like this is insane it's
insane let's grab this call hey what's
going on you're on the air who's calling
hey Dean this is bad how are you what's
going on Brad where you at today I'm up
in ventura just watching you guys
heading into work right on man you
smelling that blown up recycling plant I
know what that happen Oh up here in LA
somewhere man it just smells like the
world's getting welded oh [ __ ] no I
don't have any of that yeah man what do
you do up there and Ventura where do you
work I work at a lot of hospitals I'm up
with the surgery teams from deafening
shift man what are you doctor no no I'm
just a technician workout instrument
hmm imagine session control steps all
right how do you like living up in
ventura I like it up there a lot man a
rude and oxnard from a half-wave I know
where that is a you know it's a mile off
of the beach I just I played hooky
yesterday on my fishing no just that I
grew up in the Midwest so I'm kind of
living the life out here man it's a good
place to raise a family and i was in san
diego a long time so I like it up here
it's a little slower run out as many
people at least yeah I i often fantasize
about tapping out and i talked to a lot
of people i talk about it a lot and i
always wondered if i would get bored
just like poof all of a sudden i live in
you know ventura or oh hi or something
you know but you know do you get bored I
mean you got a family and stuff right no
I don't want to get bored me my name is
a fun yourself to go do and we're
working driving different server if I
would all that the wife and I went to a
Disney thing that the bowl a couple
weeks ago you can send that you can see
there are made yeah Little Mermaid yeah
yeah he'll sorry I got dragged off to
that but rebel Wilson was really good I
love her hello yeah I love rebel Wilson
I'm trying to get her on the podcast she
moved to LA and she just doesn't answer
my tweets which is a bummer but rubber
Wilson is [ __ ] funny there's some and
I talked about it with somebody watch
her on you to type in rebel Wilson
rapper and also rebel Wilson numchucks
she did some talk show in Australia
which is kind of like a David Letterman
Show and she's done in a few times and
each time she goes on she'll do some
talent that she has and one of them was
numchucks and this chick was
[ __ ] slinging those things man oh my
god it was awesome I was like look at
this girl and then she rapped on another
one she was doing push real good push
push it reach she did that song salt and
pepper like currell like she was an
early kid rapper I guess you know I love
that girl Wow so I and her her role as
Ursula that she happened she can perform
dude oh yeah I never I never realized
how big the bowl is I know I've done a
lot of shows or garnishes in Santa
Barbara and that's just a tiny little
spot Santa Barbara's spectacular yeah
but how would that work as a big bowl
you really gotta really got to put out
to reach everybody and everybody seemed
to be having a good time so I would love
to do comedy in there it would be so
epic you know figure speaking of a
comedy Dean oxide opening up another one
of levity lives well yeah yeah I've
known about that for about a year it's
actually been ready to go for like six
months and they're just waiting on
permits and I guess it's finally in
action it's going to open up and it's
our beautiful room have you seen it no
I'm trying to do a little clear that I
did hear the Bobby leaves going to be
coming up and I think jo koy yeah that
couple names have already kind of
slipped in on a schedule so my wife ride
was pretty big size of comedy and so
we're fired up for that room that is
going to be such a win-win because you
know there's been over the years I can't
tell you how many times I've done comedy
in Ventura at Chinese restaurants and
and bars and yoga studios and whatever
they're always were full and the people
were great the audience's yes so for
them to get a legit venue it's going to
be packed and and and you know that [ __ ]
that that area is getting bigger and
bigger it's crazy like that whole new
you uh mall you guys got up there on
yeah everyone I cool yeah so that I mean
that place is going to be epic and it's
going to be great for people like us
because it's only a drive up that you
know to Ventura it's not like a fight to
Oklahoma so if you put there for a
weekend you're not that far from home
which is great yeah yellow curry far
comfort the baby and I gotta get going
on man how to get in there but so happy
to get to talking man I hope you guys
have a good show thanks for calling and
try to come out to delray at the El Rey
I was listening to your show that [ __ ]
oh yeah you promoted that it's 10 best
to tip it off yeah me Marc Maron Joey
Diaz and a few other surprises coming
ten bucks July 19th that's gonna be fire
oh dude I gotta get after that then you
should man the venue is beautiful yeah
thanks for calling man enough good now
all riding all right Cooper yeah man
it's uh Ventura it so it's nice i
sometimes think about like wow this is
cool you know live up here my buddy
lives in Santa Maria he visa works he's
the GM for Harley up there he's got a
[ __ ] house for 1400 it's a three
bedroom three car garage in this sleepy
neighborhood that is just like awesome
and yeah he's got a good life man he
just works at Harley there's no
competition that the only deal are up
there so you don't have to worry about
people going to I'm going up the street
for a deal man he's come in either they
buy it or they don't and you go home at
night and chill it your place it's very
it sounds good man it sounds good it
gets up it gets your [ __ ] mind
running when you just see like every
time you go out crazy people are out
there and you're like wow what do I did
you know do I just want to [ __ ]
mellow out you know I've
I've been burning it up for the whole 50
years do I want to just mellow it out or
what but you know I love what I do I'm a
podcast and I love comedy I so I just I
couldn't imagine not doing that it's
like what I do but the rest of its
[ __ ] it it beats on you man it beats
on you you're just kind of like [ __ ]
this is like brutal but that's artists
you know you just [ __ ] keep rolling
and figure it out and breathe in this
this welding this welding smell I can't
believe what it smells like outside it's
got to be like yeah you're what i've
been to places and you just think back
in your life like you breathe something
in the well that that's got a couple
years on me later on you know like this
there's [ __ ] cars out there still
like those old diesels and i'll be on my
motorcycle and it's just like what is
coming out of your [ __ ] car man I
mean you know or you go buy some old
like warehouse there used to be a chrome
shop on Santa Monica Boulevard and I
would eat at Jones all the time we got
the best spaghetti and meatballs in town
Jones and it's not Joan's on third it's
on Santa Monica there was a chrome shop
there recently just closed and now
they're already building condos full
[ __ ] condo riser but I would walk by
and I'd forget some time and just
huffing this like radical chemical gas
[ __ ] and they worked at night these guys
24 7 their chrome and [ __ ] you get the
doors were open you could see the chrome
bays and they're just in there and I was
like well that got me you know whatever
that [ __ ] smell was it got me hey and
I would forget all the time I just
walked by and a half in this [ __ ] the
crazy [ __ ] I can't believe you know I
can't believe what what's out there that
we don't know about probably you know
like secret gases
you know the Sun the sun's burning us up
the food's killing us it's a dark world
man Oh crazy I I do want to talk a
little bit more about the delray at the
El Rey so it's July 19th and it I did
one of course where I turned 50 I did
the delray at the El Rey with music and
which is great yeah that was killer was
there not going to do music at this one
because it was it's a lot of [ __ ]
work a lot of work and I think that was
the downfall of my first couple months
of led up to that man i just ran the
wheels off this [ __ ] machine my body
you know it's like first I got the flu
when I was a new year's eve of their
Griffin up at what the san jose m prom
then a week later I go back out on the
road with Joey Diaz I get some kind of
bronchial infection takes out my whole
chest my ears then then then after the
[ __ ] delray at the El Rey I [ __ ] my
neck up somehow that's it's finally
going away I couldn't even come last
week but today Oh in the last three days
I finally feel [ __ ] way better on my
neck and it's funny how the doctors tell
you what to do and you just don't do it
so they're like well you got to stretch
every day for 10 minutes I did it for
like three days and then didn't do it
anymore and my neck didn't ever got
[ __ ] better then I start stretching I
get an ice pack he said I sit three
times a day I got an ice pack I start
stretching now it's [ __ ] better if I
would have just listened to them and the
beginning I would have been fixed a
month ago but you know I just [ __ ]
used to [ __ ] just fixing itself over
your years of like oh yeah that'll go
away and it doesn't go away you're like
oh this can't be like a neck muscle it's
got to be cancer and I go to
cedars-sinai to test me to go dude your
phone you got like a pulled neck
muscle he said to ice it why aren't you
I sadar cuz I'm an idiot how come you're
not stretching stretching sounds bogus
yeah i mean i remember i have
prostatitis they say take vitamin these
three vitamins I got that's not gonna
work and it worked let's grab this call
what's going on you're on the air who's
calling what up B mrs. Albemarle belly
in Washington ow how's Bellingham today
I get up there yes I little rainy but
you know it's Washington with you to do
yeah yeah my buddies riding his
motorcycle up there right now taming
from faster pussycat said it's rain oh
yeah rainin and so we've had some weird
weather here man I've actually enjoyed
it it's been just they call it June
gloom it's just cloudy and like 65 you
know every day it's nice let's [ __ ] you
bad yeah I'll take it because I know
what's coming around the corner about a
week ago we had a little preview of a
hundred degrees and I'm living in a new
place now it was my first time in the
new place with a hundred degrees and I
was like oh this is this is gonna be
[ __ ] this summer no yeah that's all I
kept thinking what do you do up there if
I talk to you before yeah I called it
once before I work at a tmobile oh
that's right I remember you now t-mobile
what's going on a tmobile man I don't
know man I don't know you keep a today's
Tuesday dough you like dominoes you can
get a free pizza for being a t-mobile
customer why how do you do that oh you
gotta download the app t-mobile
Tuesday's a hobby week man every every
Tuesday it's pretty cool every Tuesday
you can get a three me and pizza from
domino's for am A to Z every Tuesday man
what the [ __ ] man ready or not two
homeless guys and what a free movie
ticket wow so you just get the
t mobile app download it and then you
just get free pizza every Tuesday yeah
from t-mobile Tuesday's you go check it
out man I'm [ __ ] on that because I
know they don't got signal they might as
well have something right they might opt
for pizza I tell you what man t-mobile I
they make my [ __ ] blood boil you know
hey I know I work I cannot believe out
every time they say the same [ __ ] on
there on Twitter so y'all go tmobile
pretty cool no [ __ ] signal from from
the 10 baker to vegas and then they'll
tweet right away we're sorry to hear
that please DM us we want to fix this
right away it's like you're not fixing
it cell towers is how you fix it you
don't have any [ __ ] towers out here
what are you gonna do Matt and then they
don't offer to like you know lower your
bill or anything like sorry had a bad
weekend let us take 20 bucks off your
bill instead they just worried about how
to get every customer on the network
let's do another deal and get more
people more people in this network the
worse it gets you know but that's why
they do with all pizza down yeah it's
like you know you're just holding
something that doesn't work [ __ ] it
let's get a pizza i would but they I
don't have signal to fire up the app get
hunter in I know what you mean it's so
funny man I just saw that that I can
hear me now Verizon guys doing
commercials for sprint now oh really and
it opens up it says hey you guys
remember me right can you hear me now
yeah that's me but i left verizon
because all the networks are great now
now it's just all about getting a great
deal and i said no all the networks
aren't great now i don't know what the
[ __ ] you're lying you're already lying
at the top of the commercial you're my
neighborhood Sprint is a garbage can I
remember I was going to switch from
t-mobile to sprint because all's I care
about is unlimited data I don't give a
[ __ ] about anything
else and so sprint has unlimited data
too so I tweeted hey la what's sprint
like in LA and I can tell you my phone
fell apart from all the tweets of
[ __ ] it's the worst don't do it get
out oh it sucks it's crazy you got
signal in bellingham on t-mobile yeah
until I get all gotta felling ham and
then goes to [ __ ] unbelievable the place
you work at that does it I've been to a
tmobile dealer where the phones didn't
work in the dealer it was hilarious
they're like we got to put it on Wi-Fi
and I go what's that cuz you don't have
[ __ ] signal on Ventura Boulevard it
right in [ __ ] LA unbelie-- law then
they try to blame it well it's the
building's they got really thick walls
and iron iron roof here all right get
out of here man so good said it yeah
yeah we're all gonna die for those cell
phones man it's only a matter five more
years there'd be like people are falling
like flies you know why cell tumors
crazy haha I thought that will happen
nobody talks on the phone either so we
don't need the unlimited minutes we only
need unlimited data and once the verizon
figured that out they start charging you
for data and same with 18 play and you
get these [ __ ] mystery bills of oh
you use seven gigs well who's measuring
that you you know what I mean well I got
what about what I do get a stick out and
go put it in the water and see if
there's two gallons of data in there
[ __ ] i don't know about data you know i
don't know how to measure it so you can
just say whatever and you get these
mystery bills like back in the day when
it was a dollar a minute when i first
got a cell phone dollar a minute it was
insane and then at nighttime it be it
was like 20 cents a minute so you didn't
want to turn your phone on to like seven
and then if you turned it on by accident
you're like oh [ __ ] 82 dollars [ __ ]
crazy cell phones man they should all be
thirty bucks very good idea yeah and
those and those those metro pcs and all
those that are like forty dollars
unlimited everything they don't work
they don't work they say we use the same
networks as t-mobile yeah you do but you
only use for their towers not four
thousand of them you know cuz they rent
towers right it's crazy all right I
ranted on that enough what are you up to
today did oh man it's my day off so
right now I'm just chillin I was just
calling the calling the sea you know i'm
a big strokes and i know you're a strong
fan too okay that's right so listen I
entity their new EP goddamn that [ __ ]
new stroke CP is phenomenal you know
yeah you like it I love it you like it
it's all right i mean i like it but it
just you know just all the strokes just
i love it so much yeah yeah well what i
learned about me I like that first song
because it really tries to be Bowie you
know and I like that about it the
strokes could put out anything and I'm
going to be on board because we're still
doing it they're still alive they're the
original guys there's no new dudes they
are all over who you know and and and
i'll tell you what i really [ __ ] like
is Julian's last solo record that one
with the voids or whatever it's called
yeah that record is smoking man it is
smoking it sounds like some weird 80s
electronica meets early 80s uh like hip
hop it's just crazy i love it and i love
the video it's all homemade I think that
guy here yeah guy's a genius I love them
I love them and I can't get enough of
them it's so funny there was a period of
time where it's all I listened to it was
them in the eye yes you know what but
you know to me good did you get a chance
to see them play
i watch any of the footage that I'm
playing at the Governor's Ball away I
idea to go did you watch that yeah I
think they'd killed it this they forgot
it live I think yeah i love about that
band is they're rich they were rich
before they started their rich now their
parents were rich they all got money and
they had work ethic which is so unusual
for rich kids you know what i mean they
had work ever they went and rehearsed
they wrote songs they they toured their
ass off for years in Europe to get big
they you know then they got on the
[ __ ] treadmill and started playing
for years and here they are a couple
weeks ago just destroy New York City you
know and it sort of that it's incredible
because it seems like they've been
around for 20 years but I think they
came out in two thousand one or two and
so you know they've been together a long
time but it feels like they've been
around forever they're so seasoned and
yeah that's that's comes from just
playing zillions of gigs man you know
what it's great it's great i read a
great article on albert i think it was
in spin or something i had no idea that
he was just a full-blown like junkie out
in woodstock in a fortress man you know
then went out there I would feel with
his little stuff dude absolutely man
that last one was great his last solo
record was great yeah you know that's a
great band great chemistry they brought
rock back when rock needed a full kick
in the ass they wore leather jacket they
played guitars and all of a sudden they
come out of nowhere I was like well I
remember seeing them the first time and
I was like oh [ __ ] this band is killer
like they felt like new guns and roses
to me not the style or anything but the
attitude and the flavor and the the vibe
of rock and roll what I love their name
and I love
reptilia what a [ __ ] song oh yeah
take it or leave it i love other clothes
of that you take it i'll even though you
take me you know it's just like you know
the show's over no encore [ __ ] great
oh yeah I hope they tour ok tour you
know yeah I hope they do it too yeah
that's cool that you like The Strokes
you know I know there I know there's a
lot of people out there that jumped on
you know Fairweather fans like oh I love
this drugs and then years later they
it's like black crowes they just don't
bother records anymore you're like what
do you mean it's making great record
still man you know oh yeah up and I've
loved the soul since they came out I
never just seeing that I thought the
first thing with the source was like the
look they just had that look you know
what I mean till they had the [ __ ]
look man that girl's going to rock shows
again beautiful girls models and
hipsters and and like mod looking girls
and nerds you know and then dudes there
that our way into music it was just
great they had [ __ ] electric guitars
this killer thanks for going in man oh
yeah thanks for taking my call me you
have a google in there ya go ahead and
give a [ __ ] you to a tmobile for us I'll
candles with candles lit yeah oh thank
you thank you man so funny so funny yeah
strokes got new EP out if you guys don't
know it's just for songs but first song
sounds a lot like David Bowie it's
really cool and you know I could tell
it's an ode to a shout out for missing
of David Bowie and very cool so check it
out if you haven't heard it also I
wanted to say it's funny a guy was
trying to push a band on me on Twitter
quite a bit Black Angels that's like oh
yeah i'll check it out and then i
realized that i fell in love with this
band like five years ago when i looked
at my itunes this is what happens
there's so many bad
come out and you get into them and then
you listen to them for a while and then
it's out of sight out of mind man and
there's a million bands like that with
me because I'll see him at Coachella or
say festival like a Lollapalooza or
something and I'll fall in love with the
band and I'll get their stuff and then
I'll just kind of lose track so I'm
guilty of doing the same thing as a lot
of people do maybe with like The Strokes
they don't know that they put a new
record out because their life gets busy
and new records come out and you just
life moves on but anyway this band Black
Angels so I put it on again and I forgot
how much I [ __ ] love this band and
let me get the record name for you
because it is so killer and they got a
brand new record out and that's how I
kind of this guy was telling me about it
but it's on of course it's on your
trustee trustee itunes you guys got that
yet here it is a fossa fiends dream so
now you say that p hosp hene yeah I
guess so yeah phosphine stream it first
I want to play a song off this because
so [ __ ] good and get you guys into
this but the black angels really [ __ ]
cool I first heard him i was in santa
barbara is out there to see a band at
Santa Barbara Bowl and I went into the
record store on State Street they had
they used to have a great record store
they I don't know if it's still there
and this music was playing I was like
who the [ __ ] is this it just sounded
like sixties acid rock
the song's called bad vibrations
that's cool sounds like some [ __ ]
[ __ ] that would be uneasy rider you know
when they took the acid and they're just
kind of cruising around New Orleans I
could hear that song going on in there
you know really [ __ ] cool and then
let me I'll just give you a taste of
that new strokes real quick just so you
guys can but anyway that's black angels
check it out really really [ __ ] good
best roques ma'am I t mobile phone dont
have signal right now your [ __ ] phone
is just unbelievable of the data oh yeah
but now do they try to [ __ ] burn you
when you get a new phone like you're
gonna lose that cuz that's what they
were doing for a while they yeah I think
they've tried that but I'm always like
no no not yeah yeah I never they always
liked ok I was willing at first it's so
funny i meant want cell phones for so
many [ __ ] year so when i first
started it was a cellular one out in the
bay area which became AT&T later pacbell
i think it was packed bell and an AT&T
and then I was with AT&T and and they'll
sudden they just started raising prices
and and they owned for a long time they
weren't getting like any new phones it
was just blackberry only which was fun
that's all I was using but it was just
[ __ ] ridiculous so I leave them and
go to verizon which I absolutely loved
and then I did this corporate gig for
tmobile and they go come with us and
we'll give me a killer phone and and
some you know great deal on your [ __ ]
and I was like all right and then I
switched and then I go this horrible and
I try to go back to verizon ago no
longer offer unlimited data oh I [ __ ]
lose it you know it's just insane what a
bummer so I mean I'm just waiting for
the day
verizon goes back to unlimited you know
and then i'm [ __ ] gone I don't care
because it's the verizon I was out on
the road with red band we're in the
middle of nowhere and t-mobile did not
work the entire trip and I'm on a
motorcycle so if I get a [ __ ] flat or
crash and my phone doesn't work I'm
[ __ ] dead you know it's not like oh
yeah I'm good you know what's crazy is
it when when I was in Asia this December
we're out in the middle of nowhere in
Myanmar yeah going to this little temple
and there were cell towers the entire
way unbelievable these villagers have a
signal it's crazy i can go to parts of
LA or yeah like you said the desert and
have nothing the desert is yeah and then
people live there yeah it's it's just
crazy it's crazy here is some of the new
strokes here this uh just came out last
week drag queen is the song and its
really Bowie I should dig
she's
so [ __ ] good
how about it man I love it we get into
the strokes and never did wow it's just
cool to me I just it's funny i think i
love it because it just it just sit felt
so [ __ ] good you know like oh wow
what is that you know i just never liked
the vocals yeah it sounded super New
York's yeah yeah it's like new york city
cops hate that tough you know i like it
because it's it's so burnout it's like
so laid-back it was the opposite of a
frontman to me and it was of course a
lot of Lou Reed and TV television and
and you know you got some [ __ ] Joey
division in there and all that which is
which I found through the strokes
because early on and back in the 80s I
wasn't into that stuff at all as I got
[ __ ] at clove smokers you know a club
smokers and now I just [ __ ] love them
man that's what I love about music
eventually you start to like all the
music hopefully if you're around long
enough yeah it comes full circle so if
you would have liked all the music right
out of the gate it saved 14 years old
you'd have nothing to have two listed
there anymore cuz you'd be like I've
been hearing this [ __ ] since I was 14
yeah but you know I slowly discover
stuff even like that whole DC punk thing
on sonic highways I was like oh god I'm
getting into this bad brains and [ __ ]
you know all that stuff man I was anti
Zeppelin until like six years ago yeah
well a lot of people were because I
think Zeppelin was just crammed down
your throat it was everywhere and you're
just like oh I get it but to me I was
anti Zeppelin in the 90s you know I
loved loved Zeppelin on all of my love
and in through the out door record but I
was just like God Zeppelin and then i
bought a bootleg live and 77 called
destroy the Destroyers live in
cincinnati and that was it it was like a
[ __ ] shot of drugs in my arm I listen
that triple disc bootleg for a year
straight and then went down a rabbit
hole of Zeppelin that it's never ended
and now it's my favorite of all time I'm
going to get out of here what I'm going
to do is put this episode up here and
it's like I said it's going to have my
good my good friend and an amazing human
jenny is going to come on here and talk
about acting and let you guys know what
it's like to work in the business of
Hollywood as an actress and what the
hell that entails and escaping Oregon
and moving to moving to LA this [ __ ]
great story this girl has and you're
going to enjoy follower on instagram
like I said ginny Jay Wade je and nyj
Wade and and give her a shout out thanks
everybody don't forget I will be five
nights in denver colorado on jun 28
through july second Bronston Jones is
coming with me and my good friend Steve
Henry we're all going to be out there
and I'll be headlining and I'm looking
forward to that men of course Toronto
July 22nd 23rd and then New York for two
weeks thanks for the calls thanks for
all the support and thanks for listening
to the the butch Walker episode this
week what a great [ __ ] guy and get
his record August 26 butch Walker stay
cold thank you guys keep the candles lit
and keep those reviews going on iTunes
SIA